So to start with.
What i'm going to say
is you need to know
how to create classes
before you go ahead.
Starting your frogger game.
So, specifically this type of classes
is called prototypal classes.
So prototypal classes what they can do
is they have a set of attributes or
properties and
a member functions associated with it.
So let me just share my screen now
so I'm going to open up sublime and
I'm going to teach you guys how to
start typing up a very
simple prototypal class.
Let's define a class in JavaScript.
So I'm going to use this name.
So in JavaScript,
when you define a class, it should
always start with a capital letter.
So your class name should
have a capital letter.
So that is what distinguishes a class,
a function and
an object in JavaScript, because
essentially the three of them have
the same syntax or
how you define them is the same.
So what i'm going to do is.
I'm going to go ahead and
create a class and call it Person.
And I'm going to pass
in a name parameter.
Into my class.
So inside this, what I can do is
I can access the name attributor,
assign an attribute to the name
property by using this form keyword.
So that this keyword is going
to tell me the object that is
actually invocating the person class.
So the object is going to be
an instance of the person class.
So this is what I defined here.
What I'm essentially doing is,
any object I create,
I assign the object
an attribute of name and
then I give it the name that we passed
in while instantiating the object.
This will also be called as
the constructor of the class,
as you know in other languages.
So yeah so what I'm doing here is I'm
actually creating a prototype function.
So a prototype function is what it is,
is it's going to essentially create
a member function of your class.
So this function display is going to
be associated with the person class.
And it can be accessed by
an instance of the person class.
So, the technique for
that is going to be
person.prototype.display = function off.
I'm passing a greeting message
which might be just a name.
So what i'm going to do is, I'm just
going to console.log code into this.
You guys can figure out what has
happened to your game later.
And then i'm just going
to add appended greeting
to my name that I will assign this.name.
So as you can see I created a prototype
function display associated with this.
Also I can actually
create another function.
I can call an object, new person.
I can create it and.
I can call the constructor.
This way.
And then.
I'm going to pass in my name into it.
So what this is essentially doing
is it's creating an instance
of the class person and
assigning the name Poomima to it.
And whenever this object,
you do this it's going to,
this is going to return
person.name will return Poomima.
And then so
now if I want to call the display
function all I have to do
is new underscore person.
And then I can say good evening.
So the result of the new display
function should be good evening,
Poomima.
So that's what it's going to do.
So as you can see these
are prototypal classes,
you will be using a lot of this
in your JavaScript Frogger game.
>> Is there a better
way of saving states?
>> Okay, saving states for
your player object.
You can have an enum variable that
defines various states of the player.
I know that if you have a state
where the player is alive the player
is still playing when you go to like,
when you progress to levels.
You need to have you know several
enum stages in your player type.
So it's called an enumeration data type.
So what you can do is you can
have a list of states for
your player declared within
the enumeration data type.
It's going to be just like an array.
It's very similar to
an array where you can
assign these sort of like
values to it and always.
Enum data types.
Take, are in the form of caps lock
that define the state of a player.
So, feel free to use that and.
Use leverage that data type to
actually define what state your
player is currently in and what stage
you want to transition your player to.
So that's one thing you can look
at designing your states with.
>> So maybe we could talk a little
bit about how these concepts that
the students are learning could be,
so we're applying object
oriented concepts to a game.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I think from a game sense it makes
a lot of sense.
>> Right.
>> There is a player and
he's an object of enemies, and
you want to kind of create multiple
instances of these enemies so.
Having sort of this object
oriented design makes sense.
>> Right.
>> When would we see this in sort of
an actual website?
So if i'm going to, say,
ESPN or Google, any other sort
of the websites that i visit,
where on like a page would we see,
where can we utilize these
object oriented design concepts?
>> Yeah, so they could really be
used in a lot of these instances.
One of the common ones that
you'll see out there as
kind of an intro to JavaScript
development is the to-do list app.
Everyone's built a to-do list app, you
know, over and over, a hundred times.
If you think about it,
a to-do list item is pretty simple.
If you think about the properties of it,
is it checked or not?
And what is the text of
that to-do list item?
So I could easily envision a page
that has like a box at the top that
you type stuff in and
then just a series of items.
Each of those items would be an object.
And so then I would have.
I'm thinking about
the prototype of that.
Of that to do item.
Imagine we have a class
of to do list item.
Some of the prototype functions
I would have is edit because
that functionality isn't distinct or
unique between all of these items.
Everyone edits the same way.
>> Yeah,
should be able to edit it all of them.
>> Right.
Checking and unchecking,
like do you want to maybe
have a counter that updates?
So, but the checking and
un-checking functionality of that
to do item is going to be
the same across every single one.
So it really comes down to shared
functionality as we mentioned
in object oriented JavaScript course,
there's not a right way to do it.
And that's kind of the,
what I enjoy about JavaScript, is that
it just depends on the implementation.
We can't tell you always
use a function class, or
always use a pseudo classical class.
It really depends on what
you're trying to do and
what you're trying to accomplish.
And I know that sounds difficult and
frustrating.
Right now, but
it'll come in time and that's one of
my favorite things about JavaScript is.
I kind of compare it to Tetris.
It's really easy to play,
but hard to master.
That's how JavaScript is.
Is it's easy to get stuff done and
then a week later you're going to
learn something new and realize that.
I can make that better.
What i did last week and it's a constant
I can make what i just did a lot better.